for thought that we should if we're
honest with ourselves probably try to
change our career is one of the most
anxiety interesting for whole
realizations we're going to have to face
for possibly a very long time a big drop
in salary we might have back home it
will be hard to sound impressive at
parties about what we're doing and we'll
be beginning again close to zero
tellingly the agony about this can be
most potent when we young imagine
someone who's 20 they've been planning a
career in chemical engineering and
they're well on the way to gaining the
right qualifications they selected
particular subjects at school took the
right courses at university and did some
relevant work experience they've already
made what feels like an enormous
investment but now they start to think
very seriously a switching course
perhaps to walk marine biology or
anthropology it might mean another to
unforeseen years of studying at 22 we
feel that a very long time indeed 10% of
the whole of one's life so far and
psychologically it's even bigger than
that at 20 you've maybe only felt you
worth you since you were about 16 before
that you're in a kind of daze of
childhood and adolescence didn't have
any real idea of what your life might be
about so two years feels like half of
your existence it's a fast commitment
what's so hard to grasp and yet
essential is how faithfulness in a
future age say 56 from their two years
will have a very different meaning it
will only be one 20th or five percent of
the 40 years between being 16 and being
at the climax of middle age over time
the length of further study grows
relatively small against the backdrop of
a whole working life while the
consequences of not having undertaken it
grow ever larger we call this paradox
the job investment trap and it explains
why many people especially young people
mistakenly turn away from retraining the
present looms too large and a long long
future which will in fact constitute by
far the greater part of our lives
doesn't carry the basically insurance to
counter this policy we should draw up
timelines
force ourselves to see that the period
from 16 to 24 is truly quite short in
comparison with what lies between 24 and
65 we need to weigh up investments now
not against our most recent experiences
but in the light of a more accurate
picture of an entire life we need to
believe in something that's so hard to
really trust in the reality of our own
future decades of life and then we need
to dare to switch track
you